the continuing fallout from that
catastrophic winter storm that slammed
the central and southern u.s this week
at least 46 deaths are linked to the
storm texas is the epicenter of the
disaster overnight this hotel north of
austin was engulfed in flames
it was filled to capacity and most of
the guests were people displaced by the
storm
everyone made it out safely the power is
back on for
the vast majority of customers
throughout the state following
five days of blackouts and subfreezing
temperatures
but this morning a new crisis is
emerging the effects of the storm
leaving food and safe drinking water in
short supply for millions of texans
omar villafranca is in dallas omar any
good news for us
not quite yet so many pipes and water
mains burst
across the state that about seven
million people a quarter of the state's
population they don't have access to
safe drinking water
and they're under a boil advisory you
see the dallas skyline behind me that's
starting to turn back on as power gets
back on the grid
but now leaders are playing the blame
game
now what happened is ercot fell short
texas governor greg abbott laying the
blame on ercot
the non-profit cooperative that manages
almost all of texas power grid
abbott calling for state lawmakers to
investigate and to winterize power
generators
to prevent future cold weather outages
even if it means
the state stepping up providing funds to
ensure
that all of the machinery that froze up
and was
unable to generate the power you need
that may require funding
the state of texas should step up and
provide that funding but investigations
and
upgrades will wait for another day with
safe water in short supply for
millions texans lined up friday thirteen
thousand cases of water were given away
at this distribution site in houston
one of dozens statewide i'm under a boil
notice too in fort worth
but i have no water coming in my home
whatsoever i've got
six little ones that i need to take care
of up since five o'clock
and i've been on the road since six and
i know it's 11 30 but i'm going to sit
here
until i mean i have no choice
all the stores in my area are out of
water
with many store shelves bare food banks
are seeing a spike in demand
in the dallas area this weekend they're
preparing to give out 25
000 meals we definitely anticipate
there's going to be a surge
in the need for emergency food all i did
was put out the call say hey i need help
i said we'll be there
bob stevenson is one of nearly a dozen
dallas area restaurant owners
cooking and serving hot meals to anyone
finding it hard to feed themselves this
week
packing is in full swing and more help
came from hundreds of miles away
charity workers for a jewish
organization in new jersey
drove through the night to deliver
traditional friday night shabbat meals
for a dallas congregation
here we go mission dallas texas
president biden is expected to sign a
major disaster declaration which will
bring more federal aid to the state
and president biden may also visit but
only if it doesn't disrupt the relief
efforts
and jeff it's also worth noting that
mother nature is actually going to
cooperate because the high temperatures
across the state as we begin cleanup
will be in the 40s 50s and 60s
finally some good news all right omar
thank you very much